hello everyone it is Peri back here in
the studio with an exclusive Collider
interview one that I am very excited
about right now because you know how I
feel about plumb house you know how I
feel about horror and right now I get to
sit with the director of Fantasy Island
jeff wadlow how you doing yeah you
should be I feel like a Valentine's Day
opening for this one is kind of right on
the money it's sort of perfect I mean
it's kind of the ideal date movie in
that there is there are fantasies and
there are fantasies gone wrong yeah
there's a lot of fantasies gone wrong
but there's there's a nice I would even
say serious romantic tinge to it that I
wasn't quite expecting that you work in
well yeah there's some genuine emotion
it's not just like a body count or a
movie one of the big themes of the film
is regret and living your life in a
place of regret and how that can make
horrible things happen in yeah yeah you
did exactly that can we go back to the
beginning a little bit though I'm
curious to know did your idea for this
movie come up first or you knowing that
the rights were available and within
your reach so I had a general idea that
was sort of inspired by Fantasy Island
and I was talking to another producer is
actually a friend of Jason's and he
mentioned to Jason that we were working
together
Jason heard the idea and he went and got
the rights to Fantasy Island he said why
don't we just do the movie and the other
producer was very gracious he said go do
it with Jason and so we were off to the
races it seems very very much right up
his alley
yes with the kind of stuff that they
make when you were working on the script
did you ever think about maybe having
the introduction being your characters
not on the island or was that a part
where you really wanted a hold true to
the format of the original show it's
something we definitely talked about we
certainly got the note in development
wouldn't it be interesting to meet these
characters in their normal lives before
their lives are changed forever on
Fantasy Island but there is this
incredible elegance to meeting them as
the plane arrives and as the door opens
and it was such a part of the rhythm of
the show that I really wanted to embrace
it with the film in my car
writers Chris Roach and Jill Jacobs
ultimately agreed and and interestingly
enough before we even wrote the movie
and when you see the movie there's
obviously a teaser I'm talking to the
fans at home there's a teaser but
originally didn't begin with that teaser
originally the movie began on the beach
with mr. works assistant Julia and the
first line of the movie was the plane
and I always felt that that was really
important that we have that as kind of
an iconic moment very early in the film
so it is the first line of dialogue you
hear after the title I'm just curious
because the three of you have worked
together often like what is your
favorite horror movie or what's the type
of horror movie you gravitate towards
and what about the two of them because
you tap into so many different spheres
in this movie well this is a big jean
room a summary but there's time travel
there's sci-fi there's intense drama
there's actually quite a few laughs I
believe because we're basically doing
four different movies but my favorite
kind of horror is character based horror
right it's what Blum House does so well
it's when you have characters who are on
a journey there who are gonna test it
and changed by their circumstances when
you get a chance to connect with them
that's the best kind of horror because
it's not just about gore it's about
feeling something real wholeheartedly
agree with that so for fantasies here
why specifically the number four and was
there any particular fantasy you found
toughest to weave into the the overall
narrative at play well there are four
because I thought a lot about the
structure of the show you know the show
always had two fantasies over two hours
I'm sorry over one hour so we're doing
it two hour movie so four seemed like
the right number as far as the specific
fantasies you know we were just we just
started off by looking at all the
episodes we basically came up with log
lines for the different episodes we
don't watch them all again but we looked
at them all all the the plot
descriptions and we remembered our
favorites and we wrote them down and
then we started riffing and trying to
come up with fantasies that if we were
just redoing the show fantasies we would
want to see in an episode of the show
and then we started to push those
through the filter of the larger idea I
brought to the film about how they might
be all related was there any one that
was the most difficult to shoot
especially working on Fiji which sounds
like a dream come true to me but I
imagine there are some serious
production challenges that come with
that they were all difficult to shoot
none of them were easy
you know part of making a plumb house
movies that you have a very limited
budget we made this movie for 7.2
million dollars Wow not a lot of money
you know there are no trailers for the
cast no I didn't have a techno crane one
day on this movie I mean I had a techno
crane on my first movie which is a
million dollar movie didn't have any
sophisticated filmmaking equipment we
basically had the gear that we barged
over for news from New Zealand if
anything broke it was broken you know
that we just just had to figure it out
that is that's something else that that
figure on a movie that feels like it
could be for movies is pretty wildly
impressive there yes it was it was not
easy how was a cruise ship living for
you were you okay on it yes sir the
first two weeks we'll a little backstory
we couldn't find the house the the main
island location and I looked everywhere
around the more populated parts of Fiji
and we just couldn't find this colonial
looking building because by and large
you're sort of a Polynesian aesthetic in
Fiji eventually we found this building
but it was in a very remote part of Fiji
and I said to the line producer that we
got a shoot here this has got to be it
and we're coming down the wire we're
listening like maybe six weeks away from
starting to shoot and I had had a plan
but it wasn't a great plan and I said
this is a much better plan she was like
well they don't have the ability to
support us there there's no there's no
there's no hotels that the airplanes
that can land they're only like 15
Cedars we can't get the equipment there
in time and we can't do it I mean the
only way we could possibly do it is if
we bought out a cruise ship and I said
well why don't we buy out a cruise ship
so we bought out a cruise ship for the
first two weeks of photography we put
the cast the crew on it we lashed all
the gear the deck we had the kick-off
party on a Saturday night we all went to
bed in our cabins we sailed 17 hours so
the other side of Fiji we woke up we
start shooting this on the one hand this
sounds like a dream come true for an
on-location shoot it also sounds like
the start of a horror movie within a
horror movie
yeah it definitely had potential to be
problematic and I think by the end of
the two weeks everyone was ready to get
off the boat yeah the hotel
but fortunately really we just had such
an amazing
cast such a fantastic crew everyone
immediately bonded I think because we
were on the boat and we just became a
family your cast is really something
else in this when you're working with an
ensemble this big and characters that
wind up being so pivotal to each other
do you find yourself saying like this is
the character I have to cast first and
then build the in Samba around them
well mr. Rourke yes obviously had to be
cast first so grateful that Michael Pena
responded to the script they wanted to
do it I actually flew to Australia to
take him out to dinner and ask him to do
the movie and he's such a great guy
gracious guy at dinner he was like oh no
I'm already in like I told my reps I
wanted to do it you didn't have to fly
to Australia to take me out to dinner he
was there shooting Dora the Explorer so
that that was obviously the most pivotal
role that needed to be cast and then the
rest just sort of fell into place you
know some would cast very quickly Lucy
obviously I was cast very quickly Austin
Stowell is honestly the first actor that
read any words that I had written for
the movie and but we were trying to go a
different way with Patrick even though I
knew he was right and ultimately I was
just like it's Austin I mean we can't
keep trying to force this to be
something it's not Austin is the guy
yeah he got the part when the the second
he read we were just it took us a little
while to realize that you know he is it
other actors sort of emerge over the
course of the process of casting but
ultimately we got the perfect actor for
every part because one of the things I
really believe is I always cast the
actor not the role which means I'm
looking for someone interesting who
brings something from their own life to
the to them to the movie to the story
and adds all these dimensions that I
could have never fathom and as soon as I
find that I know that that's the person
I dig that approach quite a bit as an
actor's director jumping from scenarios
that are so different from each other do
you find yourself I mean maybe you
scheduled it in a way where you can
knock out one fantasy at a time but they
all they all fall in like different
subgenres do you find it challenging to
adjust from one to the other and then
back again no because there was a sort
of overriding theme of emotion and
living and regret and we tried to make
sure it permeated
every story so even though I was
attacking different genres almost within
each fantasy I wanted this to I wanted
it to have these unifying themes that
kind of brought it all together and and
to be honest my student thesis film was
very similar as a movie I made called
the Tower of Babel which was three
different stories a drama a comedy and a
thriller that ultimately came together
in a surprising way so in many ways I've
been waiting to make this movie in my
whole career that's so cool is that
available to watch I'm glad it's on it's
on Vimeo yeah [ __ ] now you know what I'm
gonna do after this I to wrap up here I
have a long answer for myself for this
question but it's a conversation we have
a lot because everyone's always like you
know we want more original stories out
there but I find that there's great
value in reboots and adaptations you
name it what does rebooting a property
mean to you what is the value to that
what do you want to bring out to
audiences who maybe didn't experience
Fantasy Island earlier well I mean I
would like to believe it's a very
original take on the on the property
when we first started discussing it I
like many fans I get tired of reboots
and remakes and this idea that they just
trot out something that we've heard of
before and just do something slightly
different and then they're like it's new
but if you're like it's not that gets
frustrating so I thought Fantasy Island
was ripe for a reimagining because so
many people have forgotten it right like
I would say if you took a survey of the
average movie-going audience probably
more than half I've never even heard of
the TV show which for me means it's the
perfect time to reintroduce it because
not only is it gonna feel fresh and new
to a lot of people have never heard of
the show but the show itself was so
great there's such great underlying
material there it's such a great idea
it's such a wonderful format for telling
character-driven stories that it should
be out there and it should be presented
to the audience so that it can become a
part of the pop culture all conversation
again
absolutely when you have a concept that
is that intriguing and also has such
opportunity for growth especially in the
time period and the kind of audience
that you're going for
whyever stop especially if you could put
your own spin on it and this is
definitely something I've never seen
anything quite like it before so Jeff
huge
gratulations to you and the team thank
you for being here today thank you for
having me I'm very excited and thanks
for watching moving of course guys keep
an eye out for Fantasy Island check it
out in theaters hits theaters
valentine's day please do not leave this
interview without liking and sharing it
you know where you should go after you
see this interview maybe our interview
with the cast or have got a brand new
episode of hocus-pocus all up and
running on the collider video and
collider interview channel we will see
you soon with more collateral